siamo entrati in questo teatro oggi con
almeno una certezza
l'essere umano l essere senziente più
evoluto del sistema solare
non c'è nessun essere vivente in grado
di creare strutture economiche culturali
e sociali così complesse come gli esseri
umani
questa certezza è talmente radicata in
noi che non ci pensiamo e pensiamo di
essere fuori sostanzialmente da una
corsa evolutiva delle spese e quindi
aver raggiunto un qualche traguardo
cognitivo non più raggiungibile da
nessun essere vivente
siamo sicuri che sia così
in realtà noi stessi siamo nel
contribuendo a creare è un intelligenza
quella artificiale che potrebbe
superarci presso tardi fino agli anni 50
molti studiosi ricercatori si sono
dedicati all'intelligenza artificiale
per creare delle macchine che potessero
risolvere dei problemi molto complessi e
quindi che non era in grado di risolvere
in altre maniere queste intelligenze si
basano fin da allora su modelli
matematico statistici in grado di
fornire gli elementi computazionali in
uno specifico dominio
così che la macchina possa
sostanzialmente a prendere quel dominio
fare delle categorizzazioni e dare delle
previsioni rispetto degli scenari che
non gli presentiamo ora non suona molto
intelligente come come definizione però
è quello che fanno sostanzialmente le
macchine in questo momento quello che
gli attribuisce intelligenza siamo
sostanzialmente noi che vediamo quando
vediamo un comportamento intelligente
pensiamo che quella gente effettivamente
lo sia in realtà tutta l'eccellenza
artificiale in questo momento si basa
fondamentalmente sulla capacità
computazionale quindi questi oggetti
hanno la capacità computazionale enorme
questo tipo di intelligenza artificiale
viene chiamata intelligenza artificiale
debole in contrapposizione con il
concetto invece di intelligenza
artificiale forte dove si teorizza la
possibilità di far
ragionare delle macchine e darle
autocoscienza dal loro autocoscienza e
farle ragionare in maniera simile
all'essere umano
questi due concetti hanno una sfumatura
diciamo varie sfumature di intelligenza
che possiamo identificare la prima sono
le macchine reattive a tenere attive
sono il primo stadio di questi tipo di
intelligenza quando riescono a fare
riescono analizzare un dominio estrarre
delle un ventaglio di possibilità e
scegliere quella migliore per uno scopo
specifico qui vedete nell'immagine deep
blue che forse una delle prime e più
famose e intelligenze artificiali di pm
che ha sconfitto il campione mondiale di
scacchi kasparov già nel 96 quando
kasparov solo qualche anno prima aveva
battuto contemporaneamente 32 computer
su in partite su ss stati degli scacchi
quindi cosa succede comincia ad
aumentare la capacità di calcolo e nel
solamente l'anno scorso google tira
fuori al fado che è un un'intesa
artificiale che gioca a go go è un gioco
molto più complesso degli scacchi e si
pensava non potesse essere battuto un
essere umano invece l'anno scorso li se
dall che il campione il coreano è stato
battuto da questa macchina ne è uscita
un'altra giusto qualche qualche mese fa
che si chiama al fago 0 che per la prima
volta riesce ad apprendere da sola
quindi al fago si basava su l'esperienza
umana per battere gli esseri umani alfa
con zero si basa sulla sua sola
esperienza quindi ha giocato in tre
giorni qualcosa come 300 milioni di
partite e adesso straccia qualunque
versione precedente di alfa 2 e quindi
questo qua è la tipica artificiale che
abbiamo in questo momento le prossime
sono quelle che
vengono chiamati intelligenze
artificiali a memoria limitata cosa
fanno questi intelligenze iniziano a
percepire il mondo che le circonda
quindi vengono dotati di sensori con le
quali riescono a creare una
rappresentazione abbastanza affidabile
dello spazio del tempo hanno una memoria
imitata quindi non riescono a mantenere
come il cervello
queste esperienze quindi non possono
usare la loro esperienza ma possono
comunque interagire maniera molto più
sofisticata questo è l'esempio qui è una
macchina a guida autonoma e quello che
si avvicina in questo momento di più a
questo tipo di intelligenza
abbiamo poi una tipologia di cui non
abbiamo ancora esempi che sono
sostanzialmente macchina che si
riferiscono alla teoria della mente
quindi aggiungiamo una caratteristica
percepisco il mondo capisco spazio tempo
e qui capisco anche che ho degli agenti
intelligenti che quindi non sono delle
degli oggetti fisici che quindi hanno
dei pensieri delle emozioni e delle
motivazioni e prendo delle agisco di
conseguenza quindi comincio a interagire
esempio con l'essere umano in contesti
diversi sociali culturali o di emozione
quindi capisco quando l'essere umano non
vuole essere scocciato piuttosto instar
abbiano risorse felice l'ultimo stadio
di intelligenza artificiale è quello
delle meno e delle intese ufficiali
autocoscienti qui siamo lontanissimi da
arrivare a questo punto è tanta che non
comprendiamo bene meno la conoscenza e
la coscienza umana e che cosa significhi
autocoscienza quindi qui c'è una tabula
rasa su cui su cosa si sistema
concentrando sulla perfezionamento delle
macchine reattive e sulla evoluzione di
quella memoria è limitata non sono solo
intelligenze artificiali dal laboratorio
o da gioco sperimentazione
parliamo di intelligenti ficiale che voi
avete già l'estate già usando avete un
portale verso questi intelligenza
artificiale che al vostro smartphone
accedere sostanzialmente a assistenti
virtuali come si ricordava google now
adesso però acceso da queste questo tipo
di assistenti virtuali si basa
sostanzialmente su algoritmi di machine
learning con in più degli agrifidi come
di diciamo analisi
comportamentale per personalizzare la
risposta alle vostre esigenze
anche qui ci si basa essenzialmente
sulla capacità computazionale e in più
sui dati molto importante perché perché
queste intese speciali come la maggior
parte del futuro si baserà su dati
prodotti da voi e voi siete il
carburante di questa intelligenza sia
per perfezionare sia per farle evolvere
cosa succede quindi abbiamo un sacco di
dati che sono nostri che vengono messe a
disposizione di di macchine e
controllate da soggetti molto specifici
cioè in particolare questo momento big
company del dell'industria informatica
con un passo proattivo di
autoregolamentazione molte di queste
industrie hi tech ha detto ok facciamo
una partnership dimostriamo che
l'intelligenza di vita è una cosa bella
positiva ci si può fare un sacco di cose
che elenchiamo nelle linee guida che noi
seguiremo in modo che siamo sicuri che
queste intelligenze artificiali faranno
quello che che serve in questo modo
diciamo si cerca di non sterilizzare un
mercato che è nascente è molto
promettente un filino diciamo contro
questa opinione è questo signore che vi
cito perché dice cosa interessante è che
solo prodotto sono a contatto con
intelligenza artificiale veramente
d'avanguardia e penso che le persone
dovrebbero essere davvero preoccupata
riguardo continua a suonare il
campanello d'allarme ma fino a quando le
persone non vedranno robot in giro per
le strade ad ammazzare persone non
sapranno come reagire perché tutto
appare così vago e ancora l'intelligenza
artificiale è un raro caso in cui
abbiamo bisogno di essere proattivi
nella regolamentazione invece che
riattivi io penso che al momento in cui
saremo reattivi nell'argomentazione di
sla ufficiale sarà troppo tardi
questo è lo dice il on mask in un
maschio per i pochi che non lo
conoscessero è un visionario
contemporanea imprenditore l'uomo che è
dietro ad aziende a straordinarie come
space ex che era per la prima volta
nella storia è stato in grado di
realizzare razzi riutilizzabili quindi
aprendo sostanzialmente l'esplorazione
spaziale e la colonizzazione di altri
pianeti per l'essere per il genere umano
o
fondata aziende di poterla che si
concentra sul rendere tutta l'energia
del mondo come sostenibile quindi
facendo centrali violette centrali
solari energia pulita e realizzando ad
esempio le prime macchine elettriche a
guida autonoma quindi uno che diciamo di
tecnologie di previsioni se ne intende
questa frase l'ha detta della sua
stanzetta nola detta di fronte al
governo americano in un'audizione
pubblica proprio per sensibilizzare e
per la prima volta diciamo è raro per
l'imprenditore americano sostenne che ci
vuole un controllo che venga
assolutamente anteposto all'innovazione
ovviamente ma nasca non si immagina i
terminator che si rivoltano l'essere
umano non c'è assolutamente bisogno di
arrivare fino alla perché perché il
punto non è quello il punto è che
l'intelligenza artificiale non sarà che
siamo intelligenti per fare cose
straordinarie e intelligenza che
intendiamo noi umana
il punto è che qui le intelligenze che
si stanno concentrando nelle mani di
pochissimi soggetti e diventano quindi
un'arma un'arma assolutamente potente e
verso la quale ha superato un certo
punto non ci potremo più ribellare ma
come fatta sostanzialmente jazz è
ufficiale ci sono tantissimi modi per
farla ma quelli più efficienti
sostanzialmente prevedono l'interazione
di un'infinità di sistemi sistemi che
interagiscono tra di loro e lavorano
dati e danno dei risultati quindi
sostanzialmente immaginiamo dei sensori
dell'elaborazione degli attuatori
ora questo tipo di architettura e ha
bisogno di un sacco di caratteristiche
diciamo tecniche non vi elenco ma
sostanzialmente parliamo di affidabilità
dei dati certificazione velocità banda
c'è tutta una serie di cose che noi
effettivamente potremmo possiamo
ritrovare in qualcosa che abbiamo già e
cioè la rete internet
ora internet nasce come una rete
distribuita purtroppo nel tempo per
questioni di pratiche prima e diciamo
opportunistiche poi pian piano diventa
una rete sempre più e centralizzata
quindi dove dei soggetti che generano e
diciamo monito non e gestiscono
praticamente tutto il traffico mondiale
con l'aumento della qualità
effettivamente dei servizi che interessa
offre
sia un aumento spasmodico di di utenti
cosa succeda questo punto i tecnici tipo
medico cavolo non ce la facciamo
l'infrastruttura non regge
cosa si fa si centralizza ancora di più
quindi quello che adesso voi chiamate
cloud è in realtà sono dei giganteschi
centri elaborazione dati che gestiscono
praticamente quasi la totalità delitti
mondiale accentrando un potere
incredibile ora fortunatamente in
parallelo a queste questo tipo di di
tendenza sono nate le tecnologie che noi
amiamo peer to peer e quindi tra pari
quindi e sostanziali sono tecnologie che
permettono di non passare da dei server
centrali per poter fare un interazione
tipico esempio è quello del file sharing
quindi la condivisione di file piuttosto
che la messaggistica piuttosto che lo
streaming video ora questo tipo di
tendenza che prima era limitata sono
sostanzialmente a una scelta morale
piuttosto che di filosofia di privacy
giusta nella privacy trasparenza
dell'informazione e quant'altro
ormai sta diventando indispensabile come
come approccio diciamo architetturale
perché il numero di device connessi
avevamo detto anche in altri talk sta
aumentando esponenzialmente qui parliamo
di decine di miliardi di device che si
inseriranno in questa rete come utenti e
quindi vorranno interagire quindi
quell'infrastruttura comunque non
reggerà
quindi stiamo andando verso delle
architetture decentralizzate cosa
significa significa andare a lavorare su
un archivio di un'architettura la prima
quella più quella più famosa anche
strumento è più potente è e schiavo c'è
la conoscenza sostanzialmente resa è
stata resa famosa negli ultimi anni in
particolare dai bitcoin che sono una
cripta ruta che sostanzialmente ha
diciamo così un po inventato la
bruciante dei suoi scopi
cosa si può fare con a bruxelles per i
non tecnici sono stati uniti immaginate
in un libro un libro mastro di
informazioni in cui ogni attore può
scrivere qualcosa non serve
l'importante diciamo punto centrale che
non serve un entità centrale per
governare questo tipo di rete qui le
informazioni possono essere scritte
validate e confermati e senza bisogno di
l'autorità centrale questo sì è questo
un fatto tramite meccanismi di algoritmi
meccanismi di consenso distribuito è
molto importante il concetto di consenso
proprio perché si responsabilizzano i
nodi e si evita di andare a affidarsi ai
singoli soggetti
ora questo tipo di architettura e
prevede la possibilità di scrivere sia
dei dati ad esempio io do l'incognita
qualcuno quindi una semplice transazione
finanziaria ma soprattutto si possono
anche creare dei piccoli programmi
la differenza con g tradizionale che qui
il programma
io so esattamente cosa farà a fronte di
un determinato evento quindi volevo
semplicissimo potrai scrivere un
programma al che praga un premio
assicurativo a fronte il verificarsi di
un sinistro ok questa cosa che adesso
viene fatta da 300 soggetti e che è
passibile di modifiche qui non so che
non lo sarebbe
in più questo tipo di reti si basa
sostanzialmente su una crittografia ai
massimi livelli attuali quindi tutto
quello che fate adesso la vostra carta
di credito
l'accessorio sia i siti bancari
piuttosto che la messaggistica online
queste tecnologie lo fanno con un grado
di sicurezza ancora maggiore e sono già
alcune pronte per affrontare il diciamo
il problema della crittografia
quantistica e cioè
la capacità di resistere solitamente
compito tremonti che sono il prossimo
stadio evolutivo diciamo della capacità
computazionale dei computer quindi
abbiamo questo tipo di rete cosa cosa
possiamo fare quindi a questo punto
possiamo immaginare la creazione di una
intelligenza ufficiale che vada
sostanzialmente a utilizzare dei
programmi siano contratti intelligenti
trasparenti e che vincolino quello che è
un intelligenza tipo artificiale può
fare del definendo i suoi confini del
suo fondamenta così che l'intelligenza
artificiale possa evolvere ma rimanere
sotto il nostro controllo
cosa serve per fare questa cosa serve
una struttura democratica e la
partecipazione di tutti gli attori a
questo tipo di intelligenza
quindi cosa si chiede cosa che dobbiamo
fare per realizzare questo tipo di
intelligenza dobbiamo sicuramente
bisogno di tecnici creare gli strumenti
adeguati a fornire la capacità di
esprimere la volontà in maniera
democratica quindi non ci deve essere un
soggetto che si può vincolare esprimere
questa volontà
possiamo rendere l'interfaccia cattiva
anzi possiamo rendere le reti veloci
possiamo fare un sacco di cose ma poi
serve qualcuno che faccia funzionare
questo berretto motore intelligente
questo siete voi voi siete quelli che
daranno i dati e daranno le indicazioni
a questa intelligenza
quindi cosa serve serve l'impegno ad
avere la consapevolezza del proprio
ruolo mentre adesso siete quindi passivi
domani dovrebbe avere questa
consapevolezza
se vogliamo continuare a diciamo
dichiararci la specie vivente più
evoluta del sistema solare non più
questa volta come singoli soggetti ma
come una entità senziente collettiva
grazie mille
[Applauso]